1006 aujourd'hui les tout le monde s'en
souvient tout le monde a été marqué à
l'époque mais aujourd'hui les gens l'ont
pardonné et même certains l'ont compris
bon après voilà libre à chacun de dans
le juger je disais en préparant cette
émission je lisais que le programme de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon a été actualisé mais
il est quasi semblable à celui de 2017
c'est assez surprenant donc ils font le
choix de la stabilité effectivement
alors ça leur rapport projet par la
gauche en disant finalement c'est une
redite mais de fait Jean-Luc Mélenchon
avait avec ce projet fait un bon score
en 2017 donc c'est un peu leur pari leur
pari de la stabilité de la cohérence
voilà est-ce que très honnêtement même
si on ne peut pas présager de l'avenir
et que tout peut arriver effectivement
d'ici l'échéance du premier tour de la
présidentielle en 2022 qui aura lieu en
avril est-ce que en l'état actuel des
choses Jean-Luc Mélenchon a des chances
d'arriver au second tour aujourd'hui il
y croit en tout cas c'est l'impression
qu'il donne est-ce que ça peut t'arriver
lui parle d'un trou de souris et
effectivement en fait tout va dépendre
de dynamique à gauche si la dynamique à
gauche s'installe derrière lui
finalement il y a une sorte de souffle
derrière sa candidature ou les
socialiste Anne Hidalgo s'effondre un
peu Yannick Jadot aussi pourquoi pas il
serait en fait le seul recours à Macron
et à toute la droite et donc dans ces
cas-là il peut espérer mais
effectivement comme ils disent c'est un
trou de souris puisque le champ de la
gauche est quand même saturé c'est très
difficile de se faire une place et voilà
de se démarquer de ses concurrents donc
avoir ensuite Jean-Luc Mélenchon voit
aussi cette élection présidentielle pour
faire durer ses idées c'est à dire qu'il
pour 2027 et même après j'ai souvent il
dit à ses proches on en a maintenant
vous en avez pour 50 ans avec nous avec
ses adversaires pardon vous en avez pour
50 ans avec nos idées parce que voilà
nous avons réussi à instaurer ça dans la
société française dans le jeu politique
et cette candidature ça permet aussi
finalement de perpétuer ce truc là de
son héritage voilà
jusqu'où il ira cet héritage de de de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon parce que la création
de l'Union populaire dont on parlait au
début de cette entretien est-ce qu'elle
ne signe pas finalement la la frein la
fin de la France insoumise est-ce qu'on
n'arrive pas en bout d'un cycle
troisième une fois que Jean-Luc
Mélenchon en son nom avec sa personne
qui porte à bout de bras une candidature
est-ce que c'est c'est pas sur la fin
est-ce que c'est pas le déclin de la
France insoumise bah ce sera assurément
en tout cas la fin d'un cycle pour la
France insoumise et pour Jean-Luc
Mélenchon parce qu'il l'a annoncé ce
sera sa dernière campagne présidentielle
donc ensuite il faudra effectivement
voir comment cette famille politique de
cette gauche radicale arrive à survivre
est-ce que derrière elle survivra il y a
plusieurs héritiers donc plus ou moins
naturel on parle beaucoup d'Adrien
katnas qui est un peu le bras droit et
le confident de Jean-Luc Mélenchon en
qu'il a une totale confiance il y a
Clémentine Notin on en parlait un petit
peu tout à l'heure qui elle aimerait
finalement rebattre les cartes à gauche
et voilà repartir sur quelque chose de
nouveau on entend aussi parler de
François Ruffin qu'on entend moins cette
campagne présidentielle d'ailleurs il
n'a pas annoncé officiellement son
soutien à Jean-Luc Mélenchon pour
l'instant donc on voilà il y a quelques
personnalités comme ça qui peuvent
expérimenter le flambeau mais
effectivement ce sera très intéressant à
suivre un des enjeux de cette gauche
voir comment elle arrive à se relever à
survivre sans Jean-Luc Mélenchon le
mélange jaunisse me semble le mélange
odisme sans Mélenchon c'est difficile à
dire en attendant vous allez pouvoir
suivre la suite de ce grand meeting de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui a débuté il y a
un peu il y a presque 25 minutes
maintenant on va vous laisser l'écouter
sans les commentaires qu'on vous a
apporté sans les éclairages de Pierre Le
Peltier qui était donc en direct avec
moi depuis les studios du Figaro
boulevard Haussmann je leur remercie
merci beaucoup pour vos éclairages et
vos commentaires nous allons donc vous
laisser avec ce meeting qui se déroule
en ce moment jusqu'à l'arrivée de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui devrait arriver
d'ici une demi-heure pour s'exprimer sur
la scène du grand espace de l'espace
grand arche à la défense à Puteaux voilà
je vais y arriver je vous laisse donc
écouter tout ceci on se retrouve à la
fin de l'intervention de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon j'espère avoir Sophie dravinel
grand reporter au Figaro pour nous
débriefer ce Cora dit Jean-Luc Mélenchon
à tout à l'heure merci
devant vous vous êtes très nombreux mais
aussi devant celles et ceux qui sont
dans les quartiers populaires et qui
souffrent au quotidien c'est pas vous
que je vais décrire la situation que
nous vivons je dis bien nous vivons
parce que je vis aussi dans les
quartiers populaires une souffrance
beaucoup de colère et parfois la colère
elle ne s'exprime pas ou parfois elle
s'exprime autrement et mais en même
temps dans ces quartiers populaires et
ça a été dit tout à l'heure par celles
et ceux qui sont intervenus dans la
petite vidéo dans ces quartiers
populaires et vous le savez il y a de la
solidarité il y a de la fraternité il y
a de l'envie et ça faut surtout pas
l'oublier et fort heureusement que
derrière cette souffrance cette colère
qui est tout à fait légitime il y a
celles et ceux qui battent le pavé tous
les jours dans les quartiers populaires
militantes militants élus militant
associatif enseignant et ça c'est
important tout à l'heure j'écoutais
j'entendais notre camarade de la FCPE
donc il y a une véritable vie mais
qu'est-ce qui manque qu'est-ce qui
manque en réalité il manque une
perspective il manque des moyens
plutôt dans nos quartiers populaires et
pourtant on se bat tous les jours pour
avoir plus de services publics pour
avoir plus de moyens pour l'école plus
de moyens pour la santé plus de moyens
je dirais pour la sécurité mais la
sécurité républicaine plus de moyens
pour en réalité faire respecter les
qualités tout simplement la dignité de
celles et ceux qui souffrent dans nos
quartiers et vous le savez moi j'ai pris
l'initiative et j'avais été très très
malmené quand j'ai pris cette initiative
il y a quelques années et ça continue
j'ai dit stop il y en a assez j'en avais
parlé avec Eric j'en avais parlé avec
des amis très proches en disant ça
suffit il y a trop de souffrance il y a
trop de colère même en même temps il y a
je dirais une force une vitalité dans
ces quartiers j'ai dit stop je vais
déposer plainte contre l'État je vais
déposer un recours contre l'État pour
rupture d'égalité républicaine et je me
suis simplement appuyé sur un rapport
dont certains parlementaires ici on
travaillait Éric Clémentine
d'autres simplement sur un rapport qui
montrait à quel point la rupture
d'égalité républicaine je précise
républicaine était défaillante était en
échec en Seine-Saint-Denis au moins sur
trois sujets l'éducation la sécurité la
justice et ça c'est inacceptable c'est
intolérable qu'on puisse accepter cela
et cette bataille pour finir cette
bataille c'est pas la bataille des élus
et de du maire que je suis c'est pas la
bataille des quelques militants ou des
militants très nombreux c'est la
bataille des citoyens de toutes celles
de tous ceux qui refusent les injustices
qui refusent des discriminations dont
nous connaissons dans nos quartiers
populaires mais je voudrais faire aussi
un lien tout à l'heure je parlais du
monde rural et quand on regarde aussi
dans le monde rural beaucoup aussi se
plaignent de voir des services publics
disparaître les transports la poste les
impôts et moi j'avais décidé en 2016 de
trouver une passerelle de trouver un
lien je vais le poursuivre dans les
semaines dans les mois à venir avec le
monde rural en particulier avec une
belle région dont j'ai une sensibilité
particulière qui est les Cévennes et
j'ai trouvé un lien avec un maire de
genolac pour justement mener la bataille
ensemble parce que quand on met de la
bataille pour la dignité d'égalité dans
les quartiers populaires quelque part on
fait grandir et on donnera résonance
aussi à la bataille dans le monde rural
parce que là aussi c'est très difficile
donc j'ai envie de dire pour conclure tu
m'avais dit 4 minutes
et ben faisons en sorte tout et tous
nous avons toutes tous cette
responsabilité à faire vivre l'avenir en
commun au plus près des quartiers au
plus près des habitants il y a
l'élection présidentielle mais au-delà
au-delà de l'élection présidentielle il
y a le travail je dirais en permanence
qu'il faut mener et vous savez ce
travail il faut le mener avec un esprit
collectif aujourd'hui on fête
malheureusement la huitième année du
décès de Mandela et Mandela disait ce
qui compte ce ne sont pas les individus
mais cette collectif donnant un sens aux
collectif donnant un sens à l'égalité à
la dignité dans le quartier populaire et
vous pouvez compter modestement sur ma
contribution merci à vous
merci
[Musique]
merci Azzedine pour
pour ton témoignage sur ces quartiers
populaires qui ont été agressés humilié
et mépriser pendant ce quinquennat qui
seront au cœur de cette campagne
présidentielle de 2022 au coeur de cette
campagne présidentielle de 2022 il y a
aussi un projet d'émancipation populaire
et ceux qui participent à ce projet
d'émancipation populaire il y a parmi
eux des artistes des comédiens des
écrivains des chercheurs des économistes
voilà encore quelques visages de notre
mouvement quelques visages de notre
Parlement de l'Union Populaire qui s'est
réuni ce matin
alors pourquoi rejoindre le Parlement de
l'Union Populaire ça c'est une bonne
question d'abord parce qu'on m'a demandé
et que lorsqu'on soutient un programme
comme je le fais pour programme de la LC
à un moment si on veut aller plus loin
comme disait en comique il faut aller
plus près donc ouais je vais m'approcher
un petit peu et regarder ce qu'on peut
faire de congrès pour une campagne il y
en a pas pour très longtemps maintenant
il y en a pour quelques semaines et
cette campagne est importante parce que
c'est probablement la dernière avant
quelque chose d'encore plus sale que ce
qu'on a maintenant pourquoi est-ce que
je rejoins le Parlement de campagne bah
tout simplement parce que je voudrais
contribuer à la hauteur de mes très
modestes moyens à la campagne qui
s'ouvre qui est une bataille qui va être
qui va être terrible on le constate tous
le fascisme ou une forme renouvelée de
fascisme du 21e siècle est aujourd'hui
à l'assaut du champ politique à l'assaut
des institutions l'une des tâches de ce
Parlement de campagne et pour les années
à venir aussi parce que c'est un travail
de longue haleine ça va être de
continuer à élaborer le sens mais aussi
les pratiques correspondantes à ce qu'on
appelle la planification écologique
c'est la première fois que je m'engage
en fait dans une campagne présidentielle
c'est parce qu'il me semble qu'une des
priorités absolues pour que une
République soit encore possible dans ce
pays c'est la reconstruction de
l'hôpital public la reconstruction de la
recherche publique et la reconstruction
du système éducatif
c'est le premier la créolisation et
l'autre la francophonie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je pense que le programme l'avenir en
commun s'il est appliqué et de nature à
améliorer la vie des citoyens et des
citoyens de ce pays ensuite la
personnalité des élus de la France
insoumise toutes et tous me semble
engagé combative et combatifs et
assoiffé de justice et puis comme on
parle d'élection présidentielle
je suis persuadé que Jean-Luc Mélenchon
est aujourd'hui le meilleur représentant
possible pour le mouvement et son
programme voilà pour toutes ces raisons
et pour d'autres ce serait très heureux
d'avoir l'occasion de me rendre utile
alors Jean-Luc Mélenchon il est seul
[Applaudissements]
et donc nous aurons la chance avec
Eric avec Azzedine moi-même de
coordonner ce Parlement de l'Union
Populaire mais il y a une personne qui
va jouer un rôle tout spécial alors
notre collectif il a travaillé ce matin
il va présenter et publier un appel que
l'on lance officiellement à tous les
secteurs de la société pour la prochaine
fois qu'on vient vous voir être encore
plus nombreux ici sur scène ce travail
va notamment être mené par une militante
hors pair vous savez quand on est des
militants il y a un peu ceux qui sont
tous les combats il y en a une qui est
peut-être représentative de tous les
combats que nous menons avec l'avenir en
commun nos chemins se sont croisés à
faucher quelques chaises de banque qui
faisaient de l'évasion fiscale
elle était attaque j'étais à Oxfam
et puis après je crois qu'elle a croisé
le fer ou plutôt la gouache avec Bernard
Arnault
elle a aussi mené beaucoup d'autres
combats c'est celle qui a dénoncé sans
relâche les accords les traités de
libre-échange qui s'est battus contre
l'agriculture productiviste bref sa vie
est un combat et c'est pour nous un
honneur et un immense honneur et je vous
le demande de le mesurer je sais pour
avoir moi-même fait ce trajet que quand
on vient du milieu associatif s'engager
dans le milieu politique c'est une vraie
décision c'est un vrai choix qui est
lourd de sens et donc aujourd'hui on a
l'honneur d'accueillir celle qui pendant
des années a été présidente et
porte-parole d'attaque le mouvement
altermondialiste
tu as porté les combats ces dernières
années je me demande la tonnerre
d'applaudissements pourront trouver
président de la Parlement de l'Union
Populaire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien bonjour à toutes et à tous vraiment
merci pour votre accueil je suis si
heureuse d'être là avec vous
et je suis ému j'ai beau avoir
l'habitude des interventions en fin de
manif ou à la fin d'un contre G7 je suis
vraiment ému d'être là je vous assure
alors je vais expliquer en quelques
minutes pourquoi je suis là avec vous et
ça va tenir en trois mots espoir
radicalité et pluralité
espoir d'abord ce que je viens du
mouvement altermondialiste et quand j'ai
commencé à militer il y a 20 ans il y a
une phrase moi qui qui me touche
toujours et que j'ai toujours à cœur
c'est un autre monde est possible je me
tourne vers Suzan George d'ailleurs qui
est ici Suzanne
qui est une grande figure du mouvement
altermondialiste
je suis là aussi parce que comme
beaucoup d'autres ici je crois que nous
disons qu'il y a urgence que l'heure est
grave parce que l'extrême droite menace
divise et c'est pas seulement Eric
Zemmour c'est pas seulement Eric zebou
il y a une poussée toute azimuts dans
une trop grande partie de la classe
politique des idées d'extrême droite et
moi je vais vous dire un marqueur
politique qui m'a décidé c'est quand il
y a eu la manifestation appelée par
quelques syndicats policiers sur des
modèles ultra sécuritaires
et bien là je me suis dit
je me suis dit il y a ceux qui ont le
courage il y a ceux qui ont les valeurs
pour ne pas y aller pour ne pas aller
manifester à côté de l'extrême droite
et donc je m'engage en soutien d'un
candidat à la présidentielle qui ne
transitent jamais avec ses valeurs là
des valeurs essentielles de lutte pour
les libertés publiques
mais il faut aussi rappeler la politique
d'Emmanuel Macron qui accélère sa
politique de cas social et écologique et
qui pour ça étouffe toutes les voix qui
sont postes à lui restera la démocratie
étouffe les libertés à coups de loi
liberticides et divise la population
en incitant le racisme dans les
institutions
le pire le pire
serait de se résigner à 5 ans de plus de
droite ou d'extrême droite et pour moi
c'est non
pour nous c'est non ne nous résignons
pas il y a des millions de citoyens qui
ont manifesté qui celui qui lutte depuis
ces deux dans ces dernières années
beaucoup de nos idées sont majoritaires
dans la population alors il va falloir
faire en sorte que tout ceux qui
partagent nos idées votre pour nos idées
que ceux qui veulent agir pour une
transformation écologique sociale
démocratique de la société s'engage dans
la politique la politique au sens noble
du terme la politique au sens de la vie
de la cité
radicalité
la radicalité pour moi ça renvoie aux
racines et en l'occurrence au racine du
système nous voulons changer les racines
du système
[Musique]
nous ne voulons plus que la plupart des
décisions économiques soient gouvernées
par la rentabilité financière au service
des plus riches nous voulons que ces
décisions soient prises en fonction de
nos besoins une planète vivable pour
demain un emploi digne pour toutes et
tous et l'égalité réelle entre chacune
et chacun
et nous savons que pour ça et bien il va
falloir faire reculer grandement les
frontières du marché qui va falloir se
confronter à des intérêts économiques
puissants il s'agit pas de changer telle
petite mesure et puis il vient de
reculer à la première contrariété il
s'agit bien de changer le système et
donc face à l'explosion des inégalités
face au péril climatiques et écologiques
et bien les bouleversements politiques
oui a provoqué son radicaux et la bonne
nouvelle pour ça et ben c'est qu'il y a
rien d'insurmontable et de mon point de
vue le programme de l'avenir en commun
en montre les voies et les moyens
pluralité enfin
parce que je pense que nous ne devons
pas avoir peur de la diversité en notre
sein et nous devons susciter le débat
dans l'Union Populaire qui sera garant
de cette pluralité
[Applaudissements]
merci Aurélie
c'est un honneur
merci Aurélie c'est un honneur pour nous
de t'avoir avec toi et Azdin tu disais
tout à l'heure que nous sommes nombreux
j'ai une annonce à vous faire
aujourd'hui vous êtes 3000 ici dans
cette salle nous avons dû ouvrir un hall
pour accueillir tous ceux qui sont venus
nombreuses et nombreux il y a 1500
personnes en plus et des gens qui
attendent dehors nous sommes aujourd'hui
plus de 5000 personnes
[Applaudissements]
salut une personne
très a changé la donne 5000 personnes
prêt à répondre
[Applaudissements]
quotidien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci
je vous en prie
merci à vous tous d'être si nombreux et
croyez
que je reçois avec un bonheur
incommensurable
l'accueil que vous me faites
je salue non seulement ceux qui sont ici
mais ceux qui est là n'ont plus y entrer
et se trouve soit dans une salle à côté
soit on du rester dehors et puis tous
ceux qui nous regardent à cet instant
sur nos réseaux et puis tous ceux qui
nous regardent à cet instant sur les
chaînes de télévision qui accomplissent
leurs devoirs civique en nous permettant
de nous exprimer devant tous les
Français qui le souhaitent ce qui n'est
pas le cas du prétendu service public
nous aurions été sans doute encore plus
nombreux si nous avions eu la salle
assez grande pour cela et bien oui nous
aurons l'heure de notre grand
rassemblement et je prends dès
maintenant le rendez-vous avec vous qui
sera celui de notre campagne en plein
air au grand jour sous la lumière du
ciel qui pour demain se lèvera peut-être
pour si longtemps si bellement si
joyeusement celle de la victoire ce ciel
ce sera celui du 20 mars une fois de
plus c'est les bras
l'anniversaire de la glorieuse
insurrection de la Commune de Paris qui
est notre mère commune
[Musique]
que disent nos rassemblements
et bien que oui nous avons besoin de
faire une démonstration de force et
d'abord à nous-mêmes qui sommes si
souvent éclatés et dispersés dans la vie
merci
c'est réciproque
[Applaudissements]
nous qui avons besoin de plus en
nous-mêmes de la force nous qu'on voit
de nouveau au corps qu'il n'embrasse
après tant d'humiliation tant de combat
parfois perdu mais toujours relevant la
tête toujours disposés au combat
toujours prêt au taux pour les autres
pour la gloire de l'humanité universelle
à laquelle nous ne cesserons jamais
d'appartenir et de nous sentir en pleine
osmose
nous venons montrer au pays pour lui
redonner du courage alors qu'il est
plongé dans l'obscurité de des bases
absurdes où l'on voudrait qu'il se conte
l'un l'autre pour des affaires de
religion ou de couleur de peau nous
venons dire et proclamer une grande foi
de plus non la France ce n'est pas
l'extrême droite la France c'est la
sécurité sociale c'est la santé publique
c'est l'émancipation c'est l'école c'est
la recherche c'est le partage
la France
fier d'être indépendantes la France qui
ne veut plus être le bagage accompagné
des guerres insensées des États-Unis
d'Amérique la France
qui croit à la République n'ont pas pour
sempiternellement parler des forces de
l'ordre mais pour ça devise Liberté
Égalité Fraternité à tout être humain
ce message ce n'est pas c'est sale que
nous l'adressons car nous en sommes tous
convaincus c'est au pays pour qu'il se
ressaisisse et prenne courage en
lui-même à ce moment que venons-nous
faire installez le Parlement de l'Union
Populaire qui est la démonstration par
ces hommes ces femmes que c'est possible
avec le meilleur de ce qu'incarne la
patrie républicaine scientifique
syndicalistes écrivains acteurs créateur
de toutes sortes voilà la France qui
flamboie crée ouvre les chemins
elle est capable
[Applaudissements]
d'incarner ce que nous lui proposons
pour demain alors oui
la France à qui nous présentons notre
carte d'identité ou de me rendre
dorénavant le tableau est presque
complet les trois familles sont là les
partisans du Grand affolement à cause du
grand remplacement monsieur Zemmour
Madame Le Pen monsieur sciotti et
quelques autres
il y a les amis du Grand démantèlement à
cause du grand rendement qu'il faut
opérer dans la société
et puis alors ça c'est Macron Pécresse
vous faites la liste que vous voulez
et puis vous avez les partisans du grand
changement à cause du grand épuisement
des êtres humains et de la nature sous
la pression du capitalisme financier qui
est en train de détruire l'humanité la
biodiversité et la planète
depuis hier
[Applaudissements]
nous avons enfin un tableau complet
puisque madame Pécresse a surmonté et
dominer ces quatre mauvais compères
et elle a dit d'elle-même qu'elle était
entière cette chair de tiers Merkel ce
qui ne laisse pas grand chose de bon
traduit
traduit en français
ça vous donne deux tiers macro un tiers
et bien il existe déjà pour les jeunes
gens qui ne le sauraient pas notamment
c'est les 100 facs à Nanterre qui ont
appris que 40 étudiants qui ont le droit
d'étudier ne peuvent pas s'intégrer à
une communauté qui compte déjà 34 000
étudiants vous voyez le déborde que cela
faisait et bien ils peuvent aller dire
merci à Madame Pécresse parce que c'est
elle qui a inventé l'autonomie des
universités comme ministre de Monsieur
Sarkozy
elle a multiplié par 4 à la région
Île-de-France les subventions à
l'enseignement privé est divisée par
deux les crédits au logement social
je vous en prie réservez votre énergie
ça va durer trois mois
son programme est un festival
réactionnel supprimer 150 000
fonctionnaires
amener la retraite à 65 ans ce qui est
pas très moderne parce que ça la ramène
au niveau où elle était quand on la crée
en 1910 comme Monsieur Macron elle
propose 6 EPR également comme Monsieur
Macron naturellement l'un et l'autre
savent comment les faire marcher car le
seul qu'on a commencé à construire a
déjà 10 ans de retard et personne ne
sait le faire marcher mais aussi
d'ailleurs la preuve ils en veulent 6
autres
et puis comme si ça ne suffisait pas
Mesdames et Messieurs chers Azzedine tu
apprendras avec quelques autres ici et
beaucoup d'intérêt que Madame Pécresse
dit que lorsque l'on sanctionne
quelqu'un par la voie de justice il
faudrait que ce soit plus sévère dans
certains quartiers que dans d'autres
autrement dit votre adresse vaudrait
circonstances accablantes
et comme elle prévoit un mauvais sujet
que vous y résisteriez elle n'hésite pas
à penser que l'armée pourrait bien après
tout participer à la répression qui
s'impose
quand j'ai proposé le blocage des prix
elle a dit ah mais je suis hostile parce
que je ne suis pas communiste mais moi
non plus et Monsieur regarde non plus
qui a bloqué les tarifs de l'essence et
même monsieur Macron qui a bloqué le
prix des masques comme ça et plus
produire en France
je lui propose le débat parce que le
débat et l'oxygène de la démocratie
parce que si vous voulez que les gens
s'intéressent si vous voulez qu'une
campagne électorale soit une campagne
utile et pas juste un combat entre des
publicités et des experts avec des
candidats qui répètent comme des moulins
à prière et des pianos mécaniques ce
qu'on leur a dit de dire c'est-à-dire
des éléments de langage mais n'ont
aucune espèce d'idée y compris sur ce
qu'ils sont en train de dire si vous
voulez qu'une élection mette en appétit
l'esprit et finissent par convaincre que
la politique est la plus grande des
noblesses qu'un être humain puisse avoir
puisque c'est le moment où cessant de se
préoccuper seulement de lui ce qui est
légitime il commence à s'intéresser aux
autres et aux solutions dont il découvre
qu'elles ne sont bonnes que quand elles
sont bonnes pour tout le monde et pas
seulement pour quelques-uns
la démocratie
est le chemin le plus direct vers le
sentiment de l'égalité et vers
l'aspiration à la fraternité c'est
pourquoi la liberté est un bien si
précieux qui s'entretient par les idées
par le mouvement de la discussion et de
la contradiction je veux débattre avec
Madame des crêtes
[Applaudissements]
d'abord
parce que figurez-vous que c'est pas si
fréquent elle a de l'humour j'ai dit
qu'elle était Ma Dalton parce qu'elle
avait réussi à venir à bout d'avril
Barnier et
de durée Ciotti
et à la répondu avec humour ah mais non
moi ça serait plutôt qu'à la mitigène
je me suis renseigné
cette Calamity jeune était l'avant-garde
de l'infâme générale Custer qui
assassiné les Indiens par paquet
et donc je ne trouve pas de sa part que
ce soit une référence qui nous donne pas
à penser finalement
alors pour elle j'ai un message d'un
Indien à lui passer
celui
[Applaudissements]
de Géronimo
quand le dernier arbre aura été abattu
quand la dernière rivière aura été
empoisonnée quand le dernier poisson
aura été péché alors madame Pécresse on
saura que l'argent ne se mange pas
[Applaudissements]
avant ça nous avons fait une découverte
on connaissait vous le savez
vous connaissez autrefois les ennemis du
peuple
dorénavant nous découvrons les ennemis
du genre humain
c'est monsieur Zemmour
pour une raison mais attendez
laissez-moi démontrer
monsieur Zemmour ni qu'il y a un genre
humain il dit à la suite d'un penseur
qui en 1796 combattait les nôtres qui
prétendaient que les êtres humains
nécessaires égaux en droit et qu'ils
étaient semblables par leurs besoins et
du coup dans le droit de chacun d'entre
eux a disposer des moyens d'accomplir
ses besoins Joseph demestre disait comme
Zemmour il n'y a point d'hommes d'être
humain dans le monde j'ai vu dans ma vie
des français des Italiens des Russes je
sais même dit-il grâce à Montesquieu
qu'on peut être persan mais quant à
l'homme dit Joseph demeestre je déclare
ne l'avoir jamais rencontré de ma vie
autrement dit il n'y a pas une humanité
universelle il n'y a pas l'universalisme
comme horizon indépassable
qui se présente devant nous et appelle
nos efforts pour en réaliser les
conditions car de l'universalisme auquel
nous aspirons en partant de la condition
qui est la nôtre aujourd'hui le chemin
est long et entravé d'inégalités de
discrimination de racisme
d'insupportabilité de l'un à l'égard de
l'autre c'est tout un chemin qu'il faut
accomplir pouvons-nous avoir confiance
dans ce chemin existe-t-il oui la vie a
démontré cela s'appelle la créolisation
comme nous l'a expliqué le point était
dedouard glissant c'est-à-dire non pas
simplement le métissage qui vous fait
aimer vos enfants par-dessus tout quand
bien même et surtout peut-être parce que
c'est de votre couple qu'ils sont nés la
créolisation c'est quelque chose qui
représente le futur de l'humanité quel
que nous soyons quel que soit notre
genre quel que soit notre couleur
quel que soit notre religion nous sommes
appelés à un moment ou à un autre à
aimer avec passion parfois détesté avec
furie
à nous asseoir à table avec ceux avec
qui nous aimons nous trouver et alors
comment ce moment magique ou le goût
deviennent communs ou ne pratique
deviennent semblable et où nous sommes
pleinement des êtres humains sans que
l'un domine l'autre mais en ayant fait
jaillir comme le dit le poète
l'inattendu cette surprise qui fait des
Français
le peuple dont le premier plat et le
couscous
elle est plus gros mangeurs de pizza de
toute l'Europe
vous qui chantez ou qui écoutez du rap
avec bonheur vous connaissez ces
mélanges de musique dont vous êtes
dorénavant c'est friand et qui constitue
pour une bonne part votre propre
identité musicale comme vous savez que
chaque génération en a une et bien vous
êtes dans la créolisation la
créolisation et l'avenir de l'humanité
c'est un bien fait ah mais comme vous
leur dites ça
les voilà quasi horrifiés
ah Monsieur Mélenchon dit monsieur
Zemmour nous on pense au joli doudous
c'est pas malin d'avoir dit ça mais vous
nous proposez la burqa pour tous
imbécile
c'est pas le sujet
la créolisation c'est cette création
commune pas autre chose
et oui c'est l'avenir de l'humanité mais
je note que la créolisation vous dérange
moins quand vous voyez sur toutes les
vitrines
un peu partout tout écrit en anglais
mais là ça fait moderne vous préférez
en définitive la créolisation maîtrisée
par les États-Unis d'Amérique à celle
fabriqué par l'immense communauté
francophone forte aujourd'hui de 320
millions d'habitants dont toute
l'énergie est en Afrique et dans le
Maghreb
[Applaudissements]
vous préférez ce qui Élise à l'Académie
française un auteur qui certes par la
magnifique langue espagnole vargasfiosa
mais qui est surtout un gros
réactionnaire qui a soutenu par tout
tous nos adversaires alors qu'il n'a pas
écrit un seul livre en français
c'est-à-dire qu'il ne s'est jamais
trouvé confronté à la difficulté du
maniement de la langue comme un outil
pour dire la chose qui est si difficile
à saisir et que la poésie parfois
elle-même n'arrive pas complètement à
exprimer la langue est un outil il faut
avoir appris à le manier pour pouvoir
participer au Dictionnaire de l'Académie
moi je dis qu'il y a des dizaines
d'auteurs francophones dont certains
sont sur cette scène que je verrai plus
volontiers à l'Académie française que ce
bavargasme en définitive
vous n'aimez que votre caste
alors bon dans tout ça nous en manque un
c'est Monsieur Macron
qui lui fait le gars qui est pas
candidat pour pouvoir abuser plus
longtemps de la fonction et bien je lui
dis que lui aussi il doit avoir
l'honnêteté pour faire vivre la
démocratie de venir dans la reine
d'accepter de débattre et notamment des
sujets que je lui ai proposé dans le par
rapport auquel il n'y a jamais aucun
débat dans ce pays et pourtant la
défense nationale ça nous concerne tous
puisqu'il s'agit de la sécurité du pays
ça nous concerne tous puisque nous
menons des expéditions absurdes dans le
Sahel ça nous concerne tous quand ils
décident de faire un état-major de
l'espace sans qu'on ne dit discuter une
minute ce qui veut dire qu'on accepte la
militarisation de l'espace et que donc
toutes les installations à terre sont
menacées d'être coupées ce qui nous
interroge sur l'existence et l'utilité
de la dissuasion nucléaire au moment où
il faudrait peut-être passer à d'autres
choses bref
il doit accepter le débat il n'est pas
au-dessus de la démocratie
[Applaudissements]
nous venons ici
au milieu d'eux nous on a dit on est là
on est là après tout ce que vous nous
avez fait on est encore là on est là et
demain on sera encore plus là vous allez
le voir très bien tôt si vous autres ne
vous contentez pas de l'applaudir quand
je parle ou d'autres mais que vous
faites le partage des tâches que suppose
l'Union Populaire l'Union Populaire
n'est pas le Congrès permanente je ne
sais quelle organisation de gauche
l'Union Populaire c'est l'union à la
base puisqu'il est impossible d'avoir
l'unité au sommet et que beaucoup ne la
souhaite pas parce qu'elle se ferait au
rabais parce qu'elle se ferait dans le
mensonge parce qu'elle se ferait dans
l'hypocrisie et qu'alors plus nombreux
serait-ce que cela dissuaderait que cela
encouragerait
voilà pourquoi ça ne s'est pas fait et
que ça ne sert à rien d'aller dans
l'endroit à l'autre en pleurnichant et
en gémissant ah il faut qu'on soit uni
parce que sinon on a perdu non n'a pas
perdu au début aussi on était peu
nombreux et pas unis contre la peine de
mort pas nombreux et peu unis pour
défendre le droit des femmes aux
élections à l'IVG et ainsi de suite ce
n'est pas le nombre qui fait la justesse
d'une cause c'est la justesse d'une
cause qui finit par faire le nombre
[Applaudissements]
la stratégie de l'Union Populaire
vous dit que puisqu'il n'est pas
possible de faire l'unité au sommet
alors faites l'Union à la base comme
ceci sont en train de le faire et ils en
ont un instrument cet instrument c'est
un programme c'est lui qui nous réunit
c'est notre force c'est la prunelle de
nos yeux c'est l'avenir en commun après
pour le reste chacun pense vie agit
convainc comme il l'entend on peut être
de toutes les origines politiques de la
gauche et même d'ailleurs on peut être
de tous les genres de toutes les
couleurs de peau de toutes les religions
et avoir sa vision du monde à partir de
là mais on a en commun un programme ce
programme nous libère ce programme rend
notre parole plurielle possible rend la
diversité possible parce que nous nous
référons à lui et que c'est lui que nous
déclarons comme un bien commun le
programme et le centre le cœur de
l'identité de l'Union Populaire alors
après bien sûr
que chacun d'entre nous s'interroge et
se disent qu'il a une mission
personnelle à accomplir dans le mot
m'est venu ce matin dans la réunion du
Parlement quelqu'un a dit il faut penser
plutôt en termes de passerelle qu'en
terme d'unité et bien quels sont ces
passerelles c'est passerelle c'est
chacun d'entre nous comme l'a dit tout à
l'heure Aurélie trouvée
ici vous êtes dans votre famille et dans
votre famille il y a de tout
et on se prend comme au nez parce que ce
qui compte c'est parce qu'on est c'est
ce qu'on va faire ensemble le futur
c'est pas ce qui va arriver c'est que ce
qu'on va faire ensemble et alors vous
pouvez venir
rejoignez nos forces à cette jérémiades
assez de pleurnicherie assez
d'hésitation au combat
à la conviction
à la maternité aux autres
mes amis
notre carte d'identité
c'est la rupture
[Applaudissements]
avec ce monde
parce que
il est temps de le faire
il s'agit de passer d'un monde où au
sommet de la hiérarchie des normes c'est
à dire au sommet de ce qui fait force de
loi au bout du bout à tout instant il y
a aujourd'hui la concurrence libre et
non fossés c'est-à-dire le saccage
autorisé et encouragé de la nature
l'épuisement des êtres humains
progressif dans des maladies sur
lesquelles on ferme les yeux comme le
diabète
comme l'obésité
comme les maladies cardiovasculaires qui
doutent résulte de la malbouffe qui
elle-même est le produit d'une
agriculture sauvage qui elle-même est le
produit d'une conception de
l'organisation de la société où tout est
marchandises et où le destin d'une
marchandise c'est de coûter moins cher
écoutez-moi cher n'existe pas
écoutez-moi moins cher coûte toujours à
la nature ou aux êtres humains qui ont
produit le moins cher écoutez-moi cher
c'est le saccage ah mais si ça coûte
plus cher alors c'est qu'il faut se
partager le moyen d'acquérir les biens
d'une manière plus juste et stopper ce
qui aujourd'hui est perçu comme un
talent une qualité en tout point
admirable au point que le chef de l'État
le propose comme rêve pour la jeunesse
être milliardaire situation à morale
immorale qui ne peut vouloir dire qu'une
chose avoir profité des autres
à cet ordre là
nous voulons substituer un autre par le
moyen du programme par le chemin couvre
le programme par ces mesures concrètes
par ces plans qui vont être mis au point
ce chemin je l'ai décris comme étant
celui d'une société de l'harmonie des
êtres humains entre eux ou les gens ne
domine pas les autres ou les uns ne sont
pas méprisés par les autres ou les uns
ne se voient pas spolier de tous les
efforts qu'ils font par quelques autres
c'est l'harmonie entre les êtres humains
et harmonie des êtres humains avec la
nature c'est-à-dire faire correspondre
les cycles de la prédation humaine de ce
que nous prenons à la nature avec les
cycles de ce qu'elle est capable de
reconstituer par elle-même et ce qui est
vrai pour la relation de l'homme à la
nature doit être vrai de l'être humain à
l'être humain dans la relation les
cycles de la vie humaine avec les cycles
de la production et de la société oui il
faut s'arrêter de travailler à 60 ans si
peut vivre plus vieux plus longtemps et
en meilleure santé oui il faut réduire
le temps de travail parce qu'on le peut
parce que la richesse globale de la
société a supposer que tout ça soit des
richesses a été multiplié par 50 quand
le temps de travail était divisé par
deux alors cette économie de temps de
travail vous avez deux manières de la
répartir soit la répartir en faisant
travailler tout le monde moins pour
travailler mieux et tous ou bien vous la
répartissez comme aujourd'hui les gens
travaillent jusqu'à la mort et les
autres restent dans le désœuvrement la
misère la nécessité et voit s'enfoncer
sans cesse le sol sous leur part il y a
la répartition humaine voulue organiser
du temps de travail et la répartition
sauvage à laquelle nous assistons et à
laquelle nous le faisons que commencer à
assister car quand les mécanismes de
l'intelligence artificielle vont arriver
là où autrefois on s'accommodait dans
certains milieux assez facilement que
les machines remplacent les hommes qui
est de contrepartie pour ceux qui
étaient autrefois sur les machines bien
sûr que la machine est là pour soulager
la peine du travailleur de la
travailleuse évidemment et nous n'allons
pas nous en plaindre à la condition bien
sûr que le temps gagné soit réparti à la
condition que celui qui vivait hier en
faisant durement avec son corps le
travail de la machine puisse continuer à
vivre dignement des revenus de sa
contribution à la vie de la société
voilà
l'idée générale
que la machine remplace que
l'intelligence artificielle a battent
les tâches intellectuelles
répétitives oui mais vous êtes mis au
pied du mur il faut changer la règle de
répartition si vous voulez que la
société soit vivable par ce quoi nous
assistons c'est véritablement
l'émergence d'une société invivable
parce que inhumaine
dans la crise que nous venons de vivre
nous avons tous soudain même si nous
n'avions pas envie de le voir pris
conscience dans certains nombre de
limites la première c'est que tout le
monde a compris qu'il n'y a pas d'autres
questions centrales qui expliquent les
autres que la question sociale s'il y a
un virus c'est parce qu'il est venu des
animaux sauvages et qu'il est passé aux
animaux domestiques hyper concentrés
dans des élevages de masse pas un n'a
été supprimé dans le monde ce qui veut
dire qu'après cette pandémie vous en
aurez d'autres derrière c'est la raison
pour laquelle dans notre programme nous
n'attendrons pas 20 ans pour fermer les
élevages extensifs ce sera tout de suite
et dans des conditions
qui soit personnellement supportable par
les paysans c'est d'accord mais la
société ne peut plus supporter ça vous
le voyez encore une fois une épidémie de
chrysalière qui commence ou dans un
élevage où il y a 160000 poules vous
appelez ça un élevage on appelle ça une
usine on appelle ça un martyrologue pour
ses pauvres poules aucun d'entre nous ne
peut imaginer qu'on traite des animaux
sensibles dans des conditions pareilles
sans hurler de rage et exiger que cela
cesse parce que ce n'est pas l'idée que
nous nous faisons de la responsabilité
du sommet de la conscience que l'être
humain face aux autres animaux doués eux
comme nous de sensibilité non la cause
des animaux ne peut pas se distinguer de
celle du bien-être humain
pas seulement parce que nous sommes
prêts à faire subir aux uns ce qu'on
fait subir aux autres mais parce que
c'est la négation de la responsabilité
de la conscience humaine face à la
biodiversité si nous sommes les
organismes vivants les plus avancés en
conscience et les plus élevés dans
l'échelle de ceux qui peuvent comprendre
alors notre responsabilité à l'égard de
tout le vivant est entière elle est au
liste elle concerne tout et tout le
monde nous sommes responsables de tout
[Applaudissements]
vous vous avez tous compris ça
mais apparemment pas eux la cop26 est
une catastrophe des paroles et des
paroles et encore des paroles si elle
continue et elle va continuer nous
aurons le réchauffement qui va faire
disparaître environ
10 000 Yunus c'est ça voilà
ça veut dire que des milliers d'êtres
humains n'auront même pu leur pays les
sous l'eau et que nous-mêmes nous allons
être rattrapés par cette montée des eaux
sur la centrale de Gravelines sur la
centrale du Blayais c'est-à-dire sur des
centrales nucléaires et bien non
seulement ils ne font rien pour prévoir
ce qui va arriver dans pas si longtemps
que ça et qui est totalement prévisible
mais ils veulent renforcer le nombre des
installations nucléaires dans le pays y
compris celles qui ne savent pas faire
marcher et puis ils vous disent
hypocritement hein vous n'aimez pas les
éoliennes devant chez vous ne vous
inquiétez pas je vais vous mettre une
centrale nucléaire de petite taille
voilà le discours qui est censé nous
rassurer Mesdames et Messieurs si ils
arrivent pour notre malheur qu'il se
passe quoi que ce soit à la centrale de
Gravelines il faudra quitter l'île
Roubaix
pour 10000 ans s'il arrive quoi que ce
soit la centrale nucléaire qui est en
amont de la capitale il faudra évacuer
12 millions de personnes et ne pas
revenir dans le secteur avant 20000 ans
la question du nucléaire n'est pas une
question idéologique nous ne sommes pas
en train de discuter si nous aimerions
ou pas la question est que le danger
existe et que plus ces centrales
avancent dans le temps que 40 17 d'entre
elles ont dépassé la limite des 40 ans
alors nous sommes dans la zone du danger
et tout à l'heure vous m'avez écouté
j'ai dû faire ma phrase rapidement en
vous disant la menace dorénavant vient
de l'espace parce que la guerre est
entrée dans l'espace c'est vrai pour
nous mais c'est vrai pour les autres
nous sommes des cibles nous présentons
58 cibles
apporter de tirs de l'espace voilà
pourquoi on ne peut pas continuer comme
ça les jeunes gens et les autres de tous
âges des écoles d'ingénieurs les
ingénieurs femmes et hommes en exercice
savent par quels moyens ils vont trouver
la solution pour aider la patrie
républicaine à se tirer de ce danger et
à produire la quantité d'énergie dont
elle a besoin sans faire courir le
risque de mort à toute la population et
à la destruction du pays
[Applaudissements]
je crois que pour l'horaire je suis
perdu ma montre me dit qu'il est 3h15 ça
c'est pas possible et lui il me dit
qu'il est 30 heures bon
non c'est dans 30 minutes
très bien alors voilà pour la rupture
écologique voilà ce que j'ai voulu dire
et je ne veux pas parier je ne veux pas
tourner autour du pot si vous mérisez je
ferai ça parce que il y a rien d'autre à
faire que ça tout le reste est une folie
mettre des petits réacteurs dans tout le
pays continuer ce modèle agricole qui
commence par tuer les paysans eux-mêmes
qui sont les plus malades les plus
atteints par les pesticides qu'il
diffuse et qui en soit empoisonne tout
le monde
ils ne le veulent pas ils font
arrêteront passés à autre chose nous
avons besoin de 200 000 paysans pour
avoir une agriculture bio partout qui
fasse que dans toutes les collectivités
toutes les cantines soient bio pour que
les enfants du peuple comme ceux du
sommet de la société puisse manger de la
même manière d'une manière saine qui ne
comprend pas leur santé pour le futur
[Applaudissements]
et pourtant
ils viennent de revoter la politique
agricole commune qui est une calamité
pour le modèle agricole que nous voulons
il continue rien ne les arrête
voyez-vous ce que je crois être la leçon
la plus importante de ce que nous avons
sous les yeux c'est que ce système est
devenu dangereux pour une raison à
laquelle nous n'avions pas pensé dans le
passé
ce système est incapable de se corriger
même devant le danger de mort autrefois
on disait de l'URSS
qu'elle était incapable de corriger ses
erreurs nonobstances qu'elle apportait à
sa population parce qu'elle n'avait pas
de démocratie et que ce qui est vrai
comme il n'y en avait pas alors c'était
difficile pour les bureaucrates de
toutes sortes de se corriger eux-mêmes
et ma foi chacun pensait qu'il continue
ce qu'il faisait et puis que c'était
l'autre qui devait s'arranger avec les
problèmes c'est vrai et le ce système
est mort de ça de l'impossibilité pour
le peuple de s'impliquer dans son destin
commun dans les nouvelles conditions
économiques qui étaient celles
particulières du système socialiste
mais dorénavant le capitalisme que
fait-il
non seulement il n'est pas capable de se
corriger parce qu'il veut prolonger ce
qui est
pour que chaque bureaucratie
chaque caste continue à accumuler mais
ce qui est pire c'est qu'ils font de
l'argent beaucoup d'argent avec les
conséquences des catastrophes qu'il
déclenche
autrement dit il y a une crise sanitaire
qui désorganise le commerce mondial
désorganise la production désorganise
des échanges mais de tout ça ils font de
l'argent parce qu'ils ont continué à
s'enrichir pendant la crise sanitaire
et cela même qui prétendait y apporter
une réponse par un vaccin
au réaliser sur la base de la diffusion
de la maladie des profits absolument
considérables approprié d'une façon
privée qui ne retourneront jamais dans
la recherche médicale et pharmaceutique
savez-vous que les trois grosses
entreprises qui vaccident ou qui propose
des vaccins accumulent chaque seconde
1000 dollars de profit
comment voulez-vous qu'un système qui
profite si heureusement des dégâts qui
l'occasionne par le biais des eonoses
s'arrête de le faire pourquoi
s'arrêterait-il ils savent comme nous
quand maintenant les élevages hyper
intensifs d'autres pandémies sont à
l'oeuvre le pas vous faire peur mais des
virus qui sont chez les animaux sauvages
transmissibles après mutation par des
animaux domestiques parqués dans les
systèmes que je vous ai décrit il y en a
je préfère pas vous dire le chiffre
sinon vous allez vous trouver mal nous
allons donc vivre dans l'ère de la
pandémie permanente aussi longtemps que
nous ne mettrons pas un terme à la cause
des pandémies mais réfléchissez encore
plus profondément
[Applaudissements]
voyez
ils ont provoqué le désastre mais ils
auraient pu l'empêcher d'une certaine
manière peut-être que vous ne le savez
pas mais ça nous fit qui était autrefois
l'orgueil de l'industrie pharmaceutique
française étant la partie chimique qui
était lié à une très grande entreprise
nationalisée et privatisée pour le
bonheur de tous comme chacun le sait
depuis
cette entreprise a renoncé
à analyser la famille des coronavirus en
2004 il y avait des chercheurs qui
travaillaient là dessus vous travaillez
là-dessus qu'est-ce que vous cherchez
vous avez même pas quoi et puis
qu'est-ce que vous allez trouver on sait
pas quoi
vous avez pas une petite molécule pour
empêcher les cheveux blancs de pas
devenir jaune quand on les lave
ça prend moins de temps et c'est plus
sûr il y a plus de clientèle ils ont
donc décidé en 2004 de cesser d'étudier
les coronavirus parce que ça prenait
trop de temps à faire entrer quelques
produits que ce soit sur le marché c'est
donc le capitalisme qui n'a pas pris et
qui a été empêché
de laisser se développer les solutions
avant que les problèmes que le
capitalisme créé c'est encore lui qui
est incapable de trouver la solution
après l'avoir déclenché donc oui c'est
vrai notre régime ce dont le programme
l'avenir en commun est l'outil c'est un
programme de transition d'une société
dominée par l'argent l'exploitation des
êtres humains entre eux et de la nature
sans limite à une autre société que nous
ne savons pas nommer à cet instant dont
j'ai parlé tout à l'heure en parlant
d'harmonie mais qui par la planification
écologique mais qui part la règle verte
mais qui part la réduction du temps de
travail
et forcément une autre société laissons
à la génération qui prendra la suite de
nos travaux après que nous ayons
appliqué le programme l'avenir en commun
le soin d'inventer ce que sera cette
suite nous nous prenons pas pour ces
prophètes qui dans le passé en politique
ont tellement fait de dégâts en
prétendant avoir tout prévu jusqu'au
moindre boulon laissons ouvertes la
porte de l'avenir mais ouvrons là
il faut d'abord l'ouvrir pour qu'elle
puisse être ensuite ouverte à la
disposition de la génération suivante
[Applaudissements]
j'ai pris une rupture avec ce système de
la gestion sanit de la crise sanitaire
ah écoutez c'est toujours la même
histoire vous avez toujours les
scronieux qui sont là chaque fois qu'on
prend une décision autoritaire ah c'est
bien il faut faire comme si il faut
faire comme ça et puis vite s'il vous
plaît dans le conseil de défense comme
ça on discute pas on réfléchit pas on
n'a pas le temps
ils ne savent pas qu'ils sont les
héritiers lointains de ces criminels qui
auraient
l'arme au poids en criant à balle
intelligence vive la mort
ceux qui ne croient pas à la démocratie
ceux qui ont peur du débat ceux qui ont
peur de la durée du débat sont ceux qui
ne croient tout simplement pas à la
communauté humaine parce que la
communauté humaine depuis qu'elle existe
elle est faite de ça d'échange de
mélange de discussion d'engueulades et à
la fin ça la conduit au seuil de la
sagesse la sagesse consiste à savoir
qu'aucune solution ne présente que des
avantages que toutes ont des
inconvénients que toute solution est
provisoire que demain on en trouvera
peut-être une meilleure c'est pourquoi
l'État républicain est toujours en état
laïque il ne se réclame d'aucune vérité
éternelle il accepte la relativité du
moment il accepte l'humilité de la
décision incomplète ou mal pensée
et je sers de nous réclamons voyez-vous
quand je reclave je regarde comment et
gérer cette crise sanitaire
ah j'ai peur pour beaucoup d'entre vous
vous aviez oublié bon ça la période où
vous étiez pas obligé de montrer votre
carte de d'identité à tout bout de champ
dans la rue autrefois c'était pas permis
il y avait des zones où on disait vous
n'avez pas le droit de la réclamer plus
loin on ne peut pas faire de contrôle
d'identité à plus de 100 mètres d'une
gare je me rappelle j'étais là après ça
a été 200 mètres et puis maintenant
c'est partout et petit à petit
s'installe une société du contrôle
permanent de tout le monde
c'est tellement vrai qu'on continue à me
dire ah le passe sanitaire c'est une
mesure plus dure non c'est une mesure
plus stupide ce n'est pas pareil
pourquoi
[Applaudissements]
mais pourquoi parce que ça vous fait
croire que vous n'êtes plus en danger
parce que pour l'avoir vous avez été
vous faire vacciner ce que pour ma part
je trouve raisonnable puisque je l'ai
fait pour moi-même pour diminuer le
risque mais je suis pas fou je sais très
bien que pour autant je peux contaminer
d'autres personnes et je peux moi-même
être contaminé
mais pourtant cette espèce de
Passe-Partout est demandé partout vous
allez voir un coup pas sanitaire un plat
de couscous pas sanitaire
tu vas regarder une expo pas sanitaire
tu montes dans le train passe sanitaire
tu descends du train pas de passe
sanitaire genre c'est là que tu ramènes
les microbes et ensuite avec ordre
contre en fonction de ce que les têtes
d'oeufs ont trouvé dans leur bureau ah
ça les lèvres on ferme toute la classe
une seule classe on ferme toutes les
codes il y en a un qui vient qui dit
attends il y a plus personne ah bon non
on a changé d'avis finalement personne
ne parle
le masque ça sert à rien oui ça sert à
quelque chose non ça sert à rien les
tests ça sert à rien oui ça sert à
quelque chose non ça sert à rien j'en
profite pour que cette réunion soit
utile à faire entendre un message
il faut à tout prix avant que ce célèbre
le plus grand rite républicain de
l'année française c'est-à-dire la trêve
des confiseurs et ces deux réveillons
que les tests redeviennent gratuits pour
que chacun puisse en responsabilité
vaccinée ou pas aller à la fête de
famille
mes amis ne craignez pas de paraître
trop rebelles ce que vous avez en face
de vous sont des menteurs et des
hypocrites chaque fois que je vais
quelque part en me dit Monsieur
Mélenchon pourquoi ne dites-vous pas
ouvertement qu'il faut être vacciné
pourquoi ne faites-vous pas si ne
faites-vous pas ça et vous avez les
successeurs de Tork et de Madame cette
cléricature qui est là pour vous dire ce
que vous devez faire et ne pas faire et
comment vous devez vous comporter pour
leur plaire qui est là sur votre dos
mais les mêmes quand vous leur dites
mais je suis vacciné foutez-moi la paix
je l'ai dit à la tribune de l'Assemblée
qu'est-ce que je peux faire de mieux
mais par contre moi je demande avec mes
camarades dans le monde entier
qu'il y ait libre accès au vaccin pour
que tout le monde puisse être vacciné
et alors où vous êtes là à ce moment-là
où vous êtes vous êtes avec moi avec
Luna ou bien avec les autres avec
Monsieur Macron pour dire qu'il ne
permettront pas que les brevets soient
levés tentez si bien que comme l'ex et
l'amandise le directeur de
l'Organisation mondiale de la santé il
n'y a pas besoin d'être un aigle pour
qu'on prendre qu'on ne combat pas un
incendie à moitié et que c'est si c'est
important que ça vous devez comprendre
n'en déplaise à monsieur Zemmour que
l'humanité est une et indivisible dès
lors qu'elle échange et quel commerce
entre elles
moi je suis pas venu ici
entretenir entre nous des querelles sans
fin
surtout celles sur lesquelles après tout
pourquoi serait-je obligé de donner un
avis depuis quand parce qu'on est en
responsable politique on devient Premier
Prix Nobel de médecine en virologie
spécialisé dans tous les problèmes ce
n'est pas vrai je dis seulement ce qui
me paraît raisonnable ce qui me paraît
cohérent à un moment de la lutte et ceux
qui peut nous rassembler parce que c'est
raisonnable et cohérent et parce que moi
je ne me moque pas de vous je ne suis
pas en train de vous dire des choses qui
changent d'une semaine à l'autre et je
vous montre à chaque fois qu'on peut
faire autrement on y a réfléchi j'ai eu
le bonheur de naître dans le Maghreb et
à l'époque il y avait des pandémies
quasi permanentes et on faisait
attention on avait tous des gestes
simples tous les jours on mettait du
permanganate de potassium pour nettoyer
nos légumes avant de les manger tout le
monde faisait ça les gestes barrières on
en faisait et bien il faudra vivre avec
des gestes barrières il faudra vivre en
faisant attention mais pas en
transformant toute la société en un
immense caserne contre les sans arrêt
par une petite poignée de donneurs de
sang
ceux qui ont fait un fichier général des
Français
devaient s'expliquer
la CNIL leur a demandé à quoi bon
pourquoi faisait-il ce fichier la CNIL
c'est la commission nationale qui
s'occupe des fichiers
oui parce que dans ce pays c'est encore
pas permis de faire ce qu'on veut comme
on veut et de croiser les fichiers
heureusement la clinique a demandé une
première fois les autres se sont dit
l'acné on s'en fout comme le Parlement
on s'en fout c'est pas pour s'occuper de
la CNIL et ben quoi qu'est-ce qu'elle
dit la CNIL voyez notre conseil de
défense ah ben c'est secret défense donc
personne parle le problème est réglé
a demandé deux fois et bien maintenant
c'est mon tour de les mettre au pied du
mur c'est votre tour alors
vous nous avez tous fait passer par la
case passe sanitaire
on a fait c'est pas toujours content on
l'a fait et ben maintenant montrez-nous
que ça servait à quelque chose puisque
c'est ce que vous demande l'avenir pas
moi Mélenchon pas vous la CNIL
donc une organisation que vous devez
respecter
[Applaudissements]
la rupture avec la gestion de la crise
sanitaire rend encore plus nécessaire
que jamais le renouveau démocratique
auquel nous aspirons voyez-vous après
tout ce qui s'est passé la crise
sanitaire ce que je viens de dire cette
catastrophe des mois durant à parler de
sécurité d'immigration de religion qui
sont des problèmes complètement
secondaires au lieu de parler des
problèmes essentiels ça fait 10 ans que
ça dure à toutes les élections se tapent
la case que les cases que je viens de
nommer et pour quel résultat ils ont
voté 30 50 lois sur ces trois sujets 50
lois c'est-à-dire une tous les 7 mois et
vous avez remarqué comme ça va beaucoup
mieux depuis
c'est un cataplasme sur une jambe de
bois ce n'est pas là que se trouve les
problèmes et vous avez besoin maintenant
de réconcilier le peuple français avec
lui-même non pas à part des bons
sentiments et des bonnes phrases mais
d'une manière active
concrète en promulguant une nouvelle
Constitution dans le peuple sera
l'auteur et non pas je ne sais qui
[Applaudissements]
ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que quoi qu'il arrive
nous savons que le niveau des
destructions sociales qui ont lieu dans
ce pays
sont elles qu'il faut dorénavant tout
reconstruire l'hôpital public que 180000
personnes ont quitté tellement il est
dévasté mais dont nous venons de
comprendre à quel point il était
indispensable et à quel point la santé
est un bien commun quand il y en a un
qui est malade il faut le soigner parce
que sinon tous les autres deviennent
malades et pas que dans un pays
disons saccagé l'école c'est le crime
majeur
pour chaque génération
l'école a été le moyen honnête
de voir ses enfants faire mieux que soi
et peut-être s'ouvrir d'autres ports
pour le futur et qu'elle fierté pour
l'enfant qui a bien travaillé ou essayer
de le faire et qui revient à la maison
avec le diplôme chargent d'orgueil et de
fierté toute la famille ici et au bled
comme moi quand j'ai été le premier
bachelier de ma famille l'école
l'école c'est la noblesse de robe de
chacun d'entre nous c'est l'école qui
nous rend meilleur c'est l'école qui
nous permet de nous émanciper
c'est-à-dire de nous libérer du pire de
tout les préjugés le racisme mais aussi
l'ignorance
l'ignorance qui vous enferme
[Applaudissements]
l'ignorance dont il faut libérer le plus
grand nombre possible
il n'y aura
qui vous tient enfermé et parfois
honteux parce que vous la connaissez
parce que il y a dans notre pays 3
millions de personnes illettrés il est
très veut pas dire un alphabète il est
très ne veut pas dire stupide souvent
quel est l'énorme richesse humaine est
perdue parce qu'on ne sait pas où la
dire ou l'écrire
comme il est difficile d'entrer en
contact avec les autres quand on a de la
difficulté à lire l'école
est le premier pilier de l'édifice
républicain parce que plus on disperse
du savoir et plus il y en a c'est pas
comme l'argent
[Applaudissements]
pour construire l'école reconstruire
l'hôpital alors écoutez assez de phrases
et de tortilly si vous croyez que
Monsieur Macron va vous reconstruire
l'école il le fera comme il vous a
reconstruit l'hôpital c'est-à-dire en
cassant tout et avec cette machine de
propagande incroyable qui fait que ce
creuse de plus en plus à un gouffre
entre ceux qui disent et ceux qui
pâtissent ce qui vous disent tous les
jours que le chômage est en train de
s'arranger qui ne reste plus que 3
millions de chômeurs alors qu'il y en a
6 qui vous disent que la situation du
pouvoir déjà d'achat déjà progresser
alors qu'il y a 8 millions de personnes
à l'aide alimentaire alors qu'il y en a
300000 qui sont sans toi alors qu'il y
en a 400 000 qui n'ont plus vous
l'électricité ou l'eau il vous disent
tout ça pour pouvoir faire en sorte qu'à
la fin vous vous disiez chacun
individuellement c'est de ma faute ah si
j'avais pas fait si bref
leur grand mot d'ordre c'est qui est
responsable de la pauvreté les pauvres
qui est responsable du chômage les
chômeurs et ainsi de suite sans cesse
culpabiliser faire intérioriser pour
couper le chemin de la lutte commune et
de la juste revendication du partage de
la richesse
et si vous avez pas bien compris
[Applaudissements]
on fera de vous
la France qui a peur
peur de tout peur du voisin à cause de
sa couleur de peau perd de la mi à cause
de sa religion
peur de tout peur de l'insécurité bien
sûr qu'elle existe mais là aussi vous
faites votre choix
c'est tel état l'insécurité mais 565
personnes qui meurent sur leur poste de
travail tous les ans ça vous défrise pas
1200 personnes qui meurent
c'est-à-dire plus que des homicides ça
vous dérange pas et que vous avez les
féminicides en chaîne comme ceux que
nous avons vécu c'est en dernier jusqu'à
ce qu'on vous ai mis la tête dans le
seau pour que vous arriviez à comprendre
que beaucoup d'entre eux auraient été
évités si on avait pris à temps les
mesures au moment de l'accueil des
femmes qui venaient déposer des plaintes
les mesures au niveau du tribunal pour
le jugement alors les meurtres
reconstruire la justice
parce que nous le ferons nous et
comprenez bien qu'il y a toujours un
plan dans leur tête ils saccage
l'hôpital public pour que vous alliez à
la clinique privée il se cache l'école
publique pour que vous alliez à l'école
privée qui saccage la justice pour que
vous acceptiez l'arbitrage la rangement
le contrat plutôt que la justice et une
société dans laquelle la justice n'est
plus en état de faire son travail est
une société qui s'abandonnera aux ventes
et à la vengeance et nous républicains
républicaine nous ne sommes pas les
partisans de la vengeance mais de la
justice et pour qu'il y ait la justice
il faut qu'il vienne les moyens de la
justice
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes prévenus
si je suis élu
il y aura une loi d'urgence sociale
ceux qui ont beaucoup gagné pendant la
crise devront beaucoup payer pour la
réparer
[Musique]
les prix de première nécessité
[Applaudissements]
seront bloqués
le SMIC sera augmenté ainsi que les
minimas sociaux
et nous mettrons aussitôt pour la
rentrée suivante les milliards qui sont
disponibles à condition d'aller les
chercher là où il se trouve
c'est à dire pas dans vos poches
nous avons besoin pour régler le plus
grand de tous les défis auxquels aucune
autre génération n'a été confrontée
avant nous qui est celui de la
précipitation de la crise climatique et
de ses conséquences aucune génération
avant nous n'a eu un problème comme
celui-là à régler il faut faire vite
pour prendre les mesures qui nous
permettent de faire face pour ça nous
avons besoin de femmes et d'hommes
ouvriers hautement qualifiés capables de
produire les machines de les entretenir
de les réparer de les inventer de les
rénover de les adapter c'est la raison
pour laquelle
nous devons produire par centaines les
femmes des hommes ingénieurs capables de
faire ce travail par milliers les
ouvriers hautement qualifiés bacheliers
professionnels brevet de technicien
supérieur dut c'est à dire toute cette
branche que l'élite économiques et
intellectuelles de cette société méprise
à plein gosier parce qu'elle ne la
connaît pas parce qu'elle ne sait pas
que 50% de la jeunesse de la patrie et
dans cette filière alors oui
j'annonce que de l'université au lycée
professionnel tout le monde bénéficiera
d'une allocation d'études de 1000 euros
par mois pour faire des études
pour faire des études apprendre vite
bien correctement
[Applaudissements]
je vous ai dit que ce système était
incapable de se corriger c'est pourquoi
j'ai pas voulu tourner autour du pot oui
nous sommes la famille de la rupture oui
nous ne considérons pas que le
capitalisme est un système indépassable
non n'a jamais dit qu'on allait abattre
le capitalisme en 694 mesures dans le
programme l'avenir en commun mais ce qui
va changer du tout au tout c'est la
direction dans laquelle on va pour
aujourd'hui vous allez dans la direction
de l'école privée vous allez dans la
direction de l'hôpital privé vous allez
dans la direction de la justice privée
vous allez dans la direction du saccage
de la planète tout sera privé et alors
vous serez privés de tout comme le
slogan a raison de le dire la direction
qui va changer
ces priorité à l'intérêt général humain
priorité à la paix priorité au
développement des intelligences parce
que nous faisons par-dessus tout le
choix de l'intelligence et moi je ne
suis pas là bondissant sur la scène à
vous dire l'innovation il faut
réindustrialiser blabli bla bla c'est
pas ça le sujet c'est comme
l'agriculture nous il y aura plus de
ministère de l'Agriculture il y aura un
ministre de la production alimentaire
voyez-vous c'est à dire quelqu'un qui
s'occupera de faire en sorte qu'on est
dans nos assiettes ce dont on a besoin
et que ce soit de bonne qualité
et bien de même on ne va pas dire il
faut réindustrialiser non c'est pas le
sujet nous allons gouverner à partir des
besoins
non pas à partir de la marchandise moins
cher mais à partir de ce dont on besoin
nos contemporains ce dont a besoin la
nature pour que nous la traitions avec
assez de respect pour qu'elle continue à
supporter notre existence et notre
écosystème gouverner à partir des
besoins
gouverner à partir des besoins c'est
tout changer et voilà le chemin sur
lequel vous vous trouverez sans doute
pour ma part et quelques autres dans
cette salle n'environs-nous peut-être
pas tout à fait le bout mais si après
qu'on est bien travaillé nous la jeune
génération s'en occupe encore plus
sérieusement et encore plus
vigoureusement peut-être que nous aurons
le temps de voir tout ça à bonne
distance et dans de bonnes conditions
car maintenant il faut faire vite
voyez-vous
l'harmonie dont j'ai parlé tout à
l'heure
qu'est-ce que ça peut bien être j'ai des
amis qui sont assez intransigeants avec
moi ils ont raison mais pas trop
et qui me disent ton truc de l'harmonie
qu'est-ce que tu fais
des intérêts qui se combattent
votre question est-ce que Mélenchon tu
nous proposes avec tes camarades là un
monde idéal où tout le monde s'aimerait
et partagerait sans qu'on ait besoin du
temps des bras
alors non ce n'est pas ça que je dis
l'harmonie avec la nature vous l'avez
compris tout à l'heure les cycles de la
prédation dans le cadre des cycles de la
nature
l'harmonie des cycles humains vous avez
tous compris c'est une affaire de
conditions de travail de durée du
travail et de rémunération du travail
mais l'harmonie à laquelle nous pensons
plus profondément je cherchais une image
je cherchais un exemple c'est pas facile
c'est pour chaque discours faut trouver
des exemples on a cherché
alors on avait trouvé Victor Hugo Victor
Hugo
pas vraiment un socialiste non mais on
l'aime beaucoup on le site sans arrêt
bon et on a trouvé finalement
une parole de femme
Louise Michel
l'harmonie dont je vous parle
c'est seul c'est cette forme de travail
commun ou l'effort de l'un s'ajoutent à
temps à celui de l'autre quand on tire
une charge quand on pousse une charge
quand on fabrique un objet qui passe
d'une main à l'autre selon le talent et
la poste de travail de langue de l'autre
cette harmonie l'effort humain cette
mise en cadence commune qui unit
l'action politique et l'action syndicale
l'action des intellectuels qui nous font
l'honneur de nous rejoindre et qui vont
mettre en mot les choses que nous disons
si mal à droitement et que savent mieux
que nous dire et intégrer au récit de
l'expérience humaine
écoutez ça
c'est Louise Michel
il était vaincu alors toujours là comme
nous et nous on n'est pas vaincu elle
dit je sens l'odeur
âcre des flots
j'entends dans les voiles les orgues du
vent
j'entends le branle-bas et le bruit des
manœuvres j'entends
le coup de sifflet
quand les matelots alentours
s'arrête
Étienne bon ensemble
j'entends le roulement rude du câble le
son des cuivres
les champs des matelots qui tirent au
cabestan
l'harmonie
c'est la force sans laquelle
il leur serait impossible
de jeter
ou de remonter l'ancre
c'est Louise Michel qui a parlé
alors
[Applaudissements]
vous allez participer maintenant après
cette course de fond qui a commencé il y
a un an avec la déclaration de ma
candidature et leur renfort aussitôt
arrivé de 260 000 parrainages de
citoyens dans l'attente
des 500 élus dont j'ai besoin pour que
notre programme puisse participer à
l'élection présidentielle à une course
de vitesse je vous connais tous bien
avant le 10 janvier il y a rien à tirer
de vous
vu que le 2 janvier c'est le week-end
précédent donc j'oublie la semaine
d'après les gamins retournent à l'école
et on se reconstitue en quelque sorte
nous voici rendus au 10 janvier et bien
ça fera pile 3 mois avant le premier
tour de l'élection c'est donc à partir
de là un sprint
il faut tous vous y mettre je dis qu'on
avait un trou de souris devant nous
moins
mais pour y arriver il faut péter
et ça je peux pas le faire tout seul
mieux tout seul ni même vous tout seul
vous ici ce qui nous écoutent que chacun
prenne sa part il n'y a qu'un combat
qu'on est sûr de perdre c'est celui
qu'on ne mène pas et celui qu'on mène
vous ouvrira des portes qui nourrit
vous le découvrez en cours de route le
nombre de ceux qui dans le monde sur
d'autres continents attendent de nous
parce que pour la France ça sera jamais
le peigne Zemmour Macron la France pour
eux ça sera toujours Victor Hugo ça sera
toujours la devise de la République et
ça sera toujours nous parce qu'il nous
connaissent ils nous regardent ils nous
suivent ils savent qui nous sommes et
ils savent que si nous faisons rompre la
chaîne du capitalisme mondialisé en
France alors elle craquera partout
ailleurs
voilà pourquoi
il dessert le contre moi cette règle que
je vois partout c'est mépris aucun
d'entre eux ne m'atteindra mieux non
plus toi qu'il arrive le baissez jamais
la tête jeunes gens quoi qu'il arrive
reprenez le drapeau qu'il venait à
tomber et il ne tombera pas
et vous tous
vive la république
vive la France et surtout vive la
république parce que sans elle il n'y a
pas de France possible
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et voilà il s'agissait de l'intervention
du candidat de la France insoumise
Jean-Luc Mélenchon lors de son premier
grand meeting qui se tenait aujourd'hui
à la défense un meeting dont vous avez
pu suivre l'intégralité en direct sur
Figaro live et sur notre chaîne YouTube
le candidat de l'extrême gauche avait
convié aujourd'hui c'est militants à se
réunir pour les mobiliser pour faire
face à la droite et à l'extrême droite
et pour montrer qu'il peut faire l'union
par la base à défaut de l'affaire avec
les autres prétendants de gauche à
l'Elysée leader de la France insoumise
intervenait au lendemain de la victoire
de Valérie Pécresse comme candidate de
la droite et quelques minutes avant la
prise de parole et l'intervention d'Éric
Zemmour qui doit également tenir son
meeting en ce moment à Villepinte 93 et
qui occupe lui l'espace médiatique
depuis plusieurs semaines les militants
des de Jean-Luc Mélenchon était au
rendez-vous en nombre il se sera semblé
en nombre pour faire contrepoids au
meeting de son opposant de Villepinte
comme nous le montrait il y a quelques
minutes encore
Sophie de Ravinel grand reporter au
Figaro qui était sur place pour nous et
pour nous faire part de ce qui se
passait et de l'atmosphère sur place
dans ce meeting de Jean-Luc Mélenchon on
l'écoute tout de suite Sophie Ravinel
alors voilà là vous voyez une vidéo
derrière moi des de tous les militants
qui se sont installés dans une pièce
dans des salles adjacentes à la salle
principale avec donc beaucoup de monde
pour ce vrai grand premier meeting de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon lancement de
du Parlement
Parlement
du jour plus de monde qui arrive pour ce
meeting beaucoup de militants beaucoup
de jeunes qui sont venus sans doute
aussi mobilisés par les meeting
peut-être de Eric Zemmour
je suis deux heures pour montrer que la
force à gauche n'est pas que la porte à
gauche et chez Jean-Luc Mélenchon
évidemment et que
Eric Zemmour si jamais ça devait être le
cas n'est pas le seul capable de remplir
des sols donc je ne peux pas
malheureusement vous montrer pour
l'instant la salle principale la salle
du meeting qui est remplie mais vous
voyez toutes les environnements qui sont
effectivement très plein ce qui est
évidemment un succès pour Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qui va pouvoir présenter cette
affluence dans son dans sa volonté de
marquer avec Yannick Jadot ça différence
Yannick Jadot le candidat des
écologistes qui sera la semaine
prochaine à la honte chez lui sa ville
d'origine dans les hauts de France
et voilà c'est un succès pour Jean-Luc
Mélenchon elle s'est militant se sont
donc rassemblés en nombre comme nous en
faisait pas Sophie dravinel grand
reporter au Figaro qui était pour nous
sur place pour nous faire part de
l'atmosphère et de la présence des
militants au meeting de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qui s'est tenu il y a quelques
minutes Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui est
intervenu un peu plus d'une heure une
heure dix à environ pour nous mobiliser
enfin pour mobiliser ces militants
contre la droite et l'extrême droite et
puis pour montrer le contrepoids qu'il
pouvait représenter face à son candidat
adversaire aux candidat adversaires Éric
Zemmour qui lui va démarrer bientôt son
meeting à Villepinte Jean-Luc Mélenchon
pour revenir un peu sur le contenu de
son discours à reprocher d'abord au
service public de ne pas faire son
travail on ne diffusant pas son discours
contrairement à ce que fait le Figaro
aujourd'hui il a tapé sur ses
adversaires sur Valérie Pécresse sur le
programme de son adversaire de la droite
également il a tapé sur sur Éric Zemmour
il a tapé également sur Emmanuel Macron
le chef de l'État et puis il est revenu
un moment sur son programme sur la cause
animale l'harmonie avec la nature il a
parlé du nucléaire des pesticides de
l'agriculture bio dénoncé la gestion de
la de la crise sanitaire parler de la
pandémie de covid-19 et les moyens pour
parvenir à indiquer les futurs pandémies
il a évidemment défendu l'éducation en
demandant et en exigeant qu'elle soit
reconstruite reconstruire l'éducation
reconstruire l'école reconstruire
également l'hôpital et la justice est
concernant la justice il a pris en
exemple le drame des féminicides qui
sont selon lui mal pris en charge par la
justice Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui
s'adressait à environ 3000 militants a
conclu sur une citation de Louise Michel
militante révolutionnaire et écrivaine
et avant d'Antony la Marseillaise je
préciserai simplement que son meeting
s'est ouvert avec le discours de Marion
excusez-moi je suis
perturber il y avait excusez-moi je
perds le fil bon on a vu Aurélie trouver
pardon qui a été largement acclamé
l'exporte boulement altermondialiste a
été largement acclamé donc en début de
du meeting de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon Marc Marion Aubry et
Éric Coquerel avons fait l'ouverture de
ce meeting premier grand meeting de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon excusez-moi je perds
mes mots voilà merci encore de nous
avoir suivi en direct sur figarolave et
sur d'autres chaînes YouTube merci
également à Pierre Lepeletier qui nous a
fait le plaisir d'être en direct au
début de la diffusion de ce direct pour
commenter l'intervention à venir de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon merci de nouveau à
Sophie dravinel qu'on aurait beaucoup
aimé avoir en direct depuis la salle
dans laquelle se trouvait Jean-Luc
Mélenchon mais pour des raisons
techniques on n'a pas pu faire ce lien
merci à tous de nous avoir suivis merci
à la Régie Vincent Rozon et ben en régie
qui était aux manettes pour la
réalisation de ce direct et à très vite
sur Figaro live